ich muss sagen ich habe immer mehr das
gefühl wir haben es dann langsam mit
einer sekte zu tun die sich begraben hat
in einem anderen universum lebt ja also
da sind die d d d d d trump mannschaft
die es noch gibt ich weiß nicht wie
viele schon von bord gesprungen sind
aber diejenigen die dort noch sind
scheinen in ihrer komplett eigenen welt
zu sein und ich weiß nicht wie das dann
funktioniert dass sie da ihre tweets
formulieren und und und und irgendwie
immer noch daran glauben ich weiß nicht
in welchem tunnel sie sind ist es auf
jeden fall auch irgendwie faszinierend
zu sehen also dass seine familie hält
natürlich ziehen das ist auch irgendwie
schön ja ich meine wir von der abwendet
das ist natürlich ganz dunkel das wollen
wir nicht aber also wenn man fragt sich
schon wie das möglich ist das schlaue
menschen die studiert haben die in einem
modernen new york washington immer leben
dass die ernsthaft diese sprache
sprechen können immer noch dass sie
ernsthaft vermitteln wollen dass sie
selbst daran glauben dass diese wahl vor
ort ist oder ob sie in einem kompletten
tunnelsystem leben also ich will fragen
faszinierten theaterstück was denn
mittlerweile aufgeführt wird
hattest du gestern auch schon mehrfach
frei steht jetzt die frage an dich
selber glaubst du denn dass sie es
wirklich selber glauben oder ich glaube
sie sind in diesem tunnel gefangen und
sie kommen da nicht aus weil donald
trump ist ihr messias und das ist jetzt
vier jahre so gewesen und sie haben
glaube ich fest daran geglaubt dass er
gewinnt dass er der beste großartigste
präsident aller zeiten der geschichte
des planeten es und das ist gar nicht
sein kann dass die menschen in den usa
so dämlich sind zum alten zu wählen das
können die nicht verstehen und deswegen
bleiben sie in diesem tunnel und bin
doch nicht acht sondern nur eine
richtung und das ist doch nicht vom
verteidigung wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren